so I'll just jump right in uh season
five is wild I've seen everything but
the last episode
um and I just love seeing your
characters uh sort of chaotic
relationship shall we say throughout the
season what was your reaction when you
found out the direction that your
characters would take this season um and
Rachel I'll start with you as always we
were surprised which has been one of the
best parts about being on this show we
never really know what's coming and so
we eagerly await that first script to
see what the Vlog we're gonna be up to
this year and
it was great I mean it was nice to see
their relationship continue to evolve
and their womans continue to Blossom and
I think for the first time in this
season
not the first time but but Anew you see
Midge trusts Susie and really give over
to Susie in a way that I don't know that
we've seen before which was really
exciting to get to play yeah I think
people have this idea that we know
what's coming you know we sit down for
the first season and they talk about the
whole show and here's what's going to
happen and we get nothing like that
every every script shows up sometimes
hours before we read them out at the
table in the middle of the night and
you're kind of finding out a bit about
your past that you had no idea about and
then you're finding out what might come
in your future it's it's crazy it's it's
like
it's like um life itself you know I
think that's what makes the show
feel so spontaneous in a way is that
you're you're living in the moment of
your character you're unpeeling it very
slowly as the audience is being fed it
yeah for sure I mean
I think it's interesting seeing you know
obviously the show is known for its
costuming and the way that it presents a
lot of its characters but in this season
specifically we kind of there's a we we
move through time shall I say
um what was it like getting into costume
for those types of scenes and filming
those
um different points in your character's
lives you are the first person that we
have been allowed to talk to about this
so
it was wild we we went through a number
of Prosthetics tests together I
absolutely horrified looking at each
other sitting in the very disturbing
what they can do now with prosthetics is
far too realistic and it's yeah you
don't want to see that folks you get a
look at your own mortality
shoot cause it ain't pretty yeah
um yeah it's interesting how wardrobe
can really reflect how your character is
changing on the inside yeah Susie
you know has always been like a belt and
a suspenders kind of gal you know super
you know super secure super scared
making sure making sure better safe than
sorry and
you know as she progresses in age she
loosens up she doesn't have to wear a
belt there's nothing to keep up she lets
her shoulders lower and becomes more
comfortable in her own skin yeah Midge
uh as you could expect continues to
deliver look after look and becomes the
chicest older lady I've ever seen but it
was fun to get to take them into the
future and to get to experiment with
slight variations on midge's signature
look her Signature Hair I remember
looking around the trailer and there
were like four different versions of
midge's wig that were ever so slightly
altered for the 70s and then again for
the 80s and the early 2000s
um
it was really really fun she had some
really great work done I should uh take
the name of her plastic surgeon yeah
exactly yeah for Susie it was getting to
let go of her exterior armor you know
her suit I think in her hat and being
bulletproof and feeling like that vest
to be
because she's scared really and doesn't
want to let anyone in and as in season
five she opens up more and she lets
Midge in more and she reveals more she
doesn't need that anymore she doesn't
have to protect herself as severely yeah
and I mean just touching on that aspect
of Susie's life we get to explore a bit
more of her sexuality shall I say in
this season specifically it becomes a
little bit more overt
um was that something that you were
looking forward to exploring with your
character and especially with her
relationship with Midge which I wouldn't
say is wholly romantic but there is like
some undertones there well I mean Mitch
and Susie are in love with each other
absolutely it's platonic it's not you
know sexual but they are they're soul
mates they're soul mates and their the
respect and the the bottom line they are
in love with each other but
I think the way Amy wrote to Susie and
exploring her sexuality I think she said
very true to who Susie is Susie would
not have let Midge in until she was
ready to let and she would not
have walked around with that on her
sleeve Susie's already this wildly
political character without trying to be
just being who she is looking the way
she looks and existing in a man's world
she's already
tackling huge things every day that she
leaves her house but that was no one
else's business and just in season five
she's comfortable enough to kind of let
her in a little bit more and kind of let
her know yes I have a heart yes it may
have been broken and that was not easy
for Susie to do and that we're friends
for real yeah like that really is the
moment where after jokingly denying it
for so long
yeah it's for real I think for Susie
season four it started when she lost
Jackie right right realizing that was a
friend and what it feels like now to
lose a friend you became even more
precious to her yeah I guess it's for
Midge that it feels like
finally
she can see something on the inside yeah
and that that means it's forever like
she's never gotten before amazing well I
want to thank you guys for talking with
me on this I love this season I can't
wait to see that final episode
um yeah I just I can't wait for
everybody to see this show